[Music]
david is in canada hi david welcome to
the ramsey show
hello hi how can we help
um well we have a question about
identity first of all both of you thank
you so much for certainly the content
you create and we're grateful for our
plan
we started in february march of 2019
with 113 000 canadian dollars worth of
debt we're around uh we're at eighty
three thousand seventy nine dollars
right now so basically eighty four
hundred you know the finish line is
imminent and tina and i kind of wanna
know like
who are we after we achieve this goal
this has been a long haul we
don't really have a strong sense of uh
where to go next
wow that's incredible so uh what got you
started on this journey that that long
ago
um a family member's inappropriate gift
a family member
gave
another family member a copy of a total
money makeover
um and uh
christina and i were you know
sort of
victims of our own lifestyle creep and
we had purchased a fixer-upper
and 99 my idea
and
it was a total total dumpster fire um it
was
by far
the
least thought out
um renovation project
in ontario
you just found yourself in a hole
you better believe it
all right so you've worked together for
three years now crushing and grunting
you're about 80 8 500 away from the
finish line what do you guys want to do
next like what do you want to do
what do we want to do dina
live life we want to own a home at some
point um
in the sort of short term
like we're married 10 years in april of
2023 i was kind of thinking that like
disney world would be nice
okay so
if you just draw another short finish
line here you're gonna just keep jumping
from finish line to finish line i want
you to do something completely different
and you've probably heard me say this on
my show a million times
um
the the best analogy i've ever heard
is
they could never go sweep up all the
glass and steel and
dust from the twin towers and rebuild
those twin towers with that dust in that
same glass and the same steel
the buildings fell and it's over right
so we have to we have to excavate it
sometimes you have to go get
professionals to help you but you
excavate it and then you have to draw
what's going to be in its place what's
going to come next and it can be
negative situations or it can be really
positive things we just the last kid
just went to college and then now what
now we get to excavate what was and we
get to completely redesign what what
comes next using all of our experiences
and talents that we've got and then lean
into what's this thing going to look
like
um dave you've been taking this question
for 30 years when people get to that
finish line okay i'm debt-free and they
scream it then they go okay now i've
still got to live with you
what have you seen that is is helpful in
help helping them rebuild reimagine
something new yeah i think you again you
set another goal but it's not a
short-term goal it's an identity goal
you you mentioned the phrase identity
and
um john you and i have talked offline
about our friend james clear book uh
james clear's book atomic habits and one
things he talks about with atomic habits
is you you clearly say
i i used to be a person that smoked now
i'm a non-smoker
okay
instead of instead of i don't smoke
anymore
now you you couch the language and
identity i i used to be a person david
that borrowed money i don't borrow money
anymore um i and and i'm a person that
wants to build wealth
and be incredibly generous
and i and i want to do all the things
that wealth
entails which is a enjoy it and b
give it and enjoy even more the
generosity of it um and that's my
reasoning for continuing to build wealth
i i have never suggested nor have i
personally done a thing where i build
wealth just for the purpose of a single
vacation or for a or for the purpose of
being wealthy
i'm not trying to be wealthy i'm trying
to do the things that wealth does
and so that's an identity i i'm a i'm a
wealthy person that enjoys money and
incredible generosity and that's my
identity and i decided that after i was
a person that went bankrupt
and so right david if you think about
identity as that new building
my wife and i we sat down years ago and
we
uh we're trying to figure out what our
marriage is gonna look like what new
work was gonna look like and we actually
made uh it's a small
we did it like with the kid with with
our oldest son at the time but we just
made a
uh it was like a craft project basically
but it was here's who the deloney's are
going to be
we're going to be people who fill in the
blood we we're people who say yes we're
people who have others over and those
decisions shaped the house that we
bought it shapes how we save money it
shapes the jobs i did or didn't take
because it all leaned back to how do
these actions back up
and support this new identity this new
building that we're building you see
what i'm saying yeah sharon and i got as
an another a minute example of that too
is um
sharon and i it took us a little while
to realize we uh
are not people who enjoy
uh
passive vacations
we don't sit
right we go
so if we're if we're going to africa
we're going to go all over the place and
see every freaking animal
you know we're not going to sit and hope
the animal wanders by
you know i mean we're out there hunting
them with a camera right and so uh
we're in action and so we plan
the the vacations in that regard other
people want to go and sit and put their
feet in the sand and read a book and
never move
uh i can do that at home personally so i
don't do that but but we just that's a
nuanced thing we decided and both of us
enjoy that type of travel and so when
we're booking travel it's action
oriented travel but to reverse
engineering
or event travel you start taking golf
lessons right and because i want to be
out moving and doing things so i'm going
to learn how to do this thing so it it
impacted your actions on a day-to-day
basis
for these things later on right and i'm
a guy who
i naturally in the evening when i'm at
home and someone says hey let's come
back out let's let's we're gonna go grab
something to eat we're gonna watch the
fights my inclination is i'm just gonna
sit here but i had said i'm gonna be a
guy who says yes to things who goes on
adventures and so i dragged myself out
i'm gonna get you you're a guy that used
to be in debt david now you're a guy
that is getting out of debt and now
you're a guy the next step is you're a
guy that doesn't borrow money yep
i used to but i don't borrow money
anymore i used to smoke i don't smoke
anymore i i didn't but i mean that's
what clear talks about the that's right
changing the language that in that
states the identity and that's not
positive thinking it's observation i am
no longer that person that's right i am
now this person i i think the the
positive thinking movement
that goes with your book that's exactly
right
in fact i talk about that one of the
chapters yeah own your passion for your
future yeah is creating this this
identity moving forward and so david
i see this as a moment like one of the
few moments in your adult life and
you'll do this you know four five six
times
when you get to plan and shape what this
thing looks like and it's going to be
loosely held of course but
what a cool exercise to go spend a half
day retreat with your wife and say okay
we're not running for our lives anymore
yeah what do we want this thing to look
like yeah now i'm a person that doesn't
eat 63 doughnuts yeah i was unbelievably
fat during covent
but i'm not anymore and i'm not going to
self-identify as a person who eats every
donut in a 50-mile radius i have done it
in the past but i cannot do that because
i get as big as this room i look like
the marshmallow and for for lent i gave
up sugar this year which was a battle
you know that that was hard but
instead of saying i'm not i'm not i'm
not
i said i'm a guy who doesn't eat sugar
right and i just didn't dave and i wish
i could tell you why or how it was a
light switch for me i just don't there's
something about the language change that
in well out of the abundance of the
heart the mouth speaks that's it man so
it's biblical but the uh this idea that
you reset your mind and you go
i used to be a person that
did that but i'm now i'm this person now
i'm a pr i don't i'm a person doesn't
borrow money and i'm pursuing wealth for
the purpose of enjoyment and generosity
and changing my family tree
you know what an identity man yeah and
so you just give yourself a different
way of looking at things and and you can
do that at 84 years old and you can do
it at 24 years old it's not an age thing
it's a decision thing congratulations
really good question way to go david by
the way way to go